well because we wanted an eye catching
bus which would go round the country and
we as women politicians in the Labour
Party talking to women in this country
listening to their views because 9.1
million women in this country didn't
vote in the last general election and
they just didn't bother to vote at all
because they don't think politics is
talking to them or listening to them so
we've got our woman-to-woman tour it's
on the road and you know as far as the
comments about the color is concerned
let's see what happens you know it's an
experiment this hasn't been done before
specifically women politicians going to
listen to women about their concerns and
about politics and let's see what they
let's not pass judgment right away when
you know we've only just gone half a
mile between the supermarket in here
where we are now let's see what what the
result is that's fair enough is a long
road in the campaign trail but as far as
passing judgments concern there is as
far as passing judgments concerned
certainly on Twitter and pretty much
every broadsheet newspaper in the
country they've all come against it
really they've also all questioned why
pink it's patronizing to women they're
saying let's just take another look I
know you can't see it but I'm going to
show our viewers another pink bus famous
amongst the under-12 females in this
country the bar being bassets pretty
similar color we just put them both side
by side now people feminist women have
been fighting for years against this
stereotyping of pink associating it with
women are you setting that cause back
decades no we're basically really
drawing attention to the fact that
actually we are there as labor women
politicians we want to discuss with
women what their concerns I why they can
say to I think what r a message to the
audience's that you're trying to reach
well because it's an eye-catching color
and you know if women are going to
object to it and they don't want to talk
to us that's fine but let's not you know
write it off before it's even begun and
I think the fact that 9.1 million women
in this country didn't vote that women
still have got problems with child care
that still there's unequal pay that
there's still problems with domestic
violence that politics is still
male-dominated
those are all important and serious
issues and this bus is not just a color
it's about something it's about our
democracy it's quite a small bus but
it's a very big issue